meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen wer weiß mehr dem großen bis
rund um mein gast diesmal ist es
commander krieger und er muss fragen
beantworten aus wissensgebieten wo er
sich eigentlich genau aus chemnitz sind
gespannt
mich vorbereiten passt auf chris gar
nicht
du hast so vorbereitet dass wir die
fragen eigentlich auf deinem fachwissen
exakt vorbereitet
einfach
die kinder gespannten mal gespannt ob
die kollegen richtig liegen
wir kommen zur ersten frage
wie viele abonnenten hat der letzt
player elo trinks
patrick scott riggs ok helau tricks 200
2740 als ist sieht sie auch den
achtzehnten achten 2012 21 uhr
also das war
wir sind sie entwenden also 202.000 47
200 9850 c200 10.560 oder dix oder
30.000 15
also ich muss erstmal sagen gerade
dieses abonnenten gewöhnt dass es
eigentlich für mich nur wichtig bei der
gamescom wenn man bei einem presse stand
ist das ist einfach es muss ganz lange
trailer schwanzvergleich sorry dass ich
das mal so sagen muss man gehe nirgendwo
hin
aber ich bin commander krieger 200
schlachtungen abonnenten dann kommt ich
bin klingt da konnte ich mit der 160
also ich noch nie die abonnenten ist
scheißegal gefällt den leuten das was
man macht
das ist die hauptsache was hat man den
alten b und c weil er hat auf jeden fall
mehr als ich okay b 209 1850 rc 270.000
block sein okay es sind leider b 209
1058 gestern ab
habe ich kein problem ist ja eigentlich
jetzt an
wie findest du es dass er mit weniger
aufwand in der community größer ist es
ist mir scheißegal ich gucke meine
videos an meine jungs müssen wir
gefallen ich muss dahinter stehen was
ich verkaufe und das tue ich
das ist schon richtig weil sonst er ist
wird ein bescheid
wer war der nach punkten erfolgreichste
werfer der letzten ende saison nach
punkten nach punkten doch nowitzki
b james c kevin rans de
lebron james denton den porträts
rockstar sein er lockte sein
und das ist richtig 30 5 697 spiegel
sind genial
ok anderes fach dem von dir wie viele
punkte holte von thun wie viele punkte
heute mottola düsseldorf in der
bundesliga saison 1996 97 9
das ist scheißegal da haben wir gar
nicht viel holen doch oder sogar
gestiegen
da sind wir abgestiegen man genau das
ist in diesen ersten bundesliga luft
schnuppern und fortuna düsseldorf bietet
mehr als nur fußball skandal spiel gegen
hertha und jetzt wieder hin
benfica lissabon da wird der shelley
umgeklappt mehr als nur fußball bei
fortuna günstiger davon die frage a 33 b
42 10 25 oder dem 39
ich hoffe einfach charlene c25
okay es war ein gericht soll sie auch
ein bisschen schwer seien kein thema
also 96 97 da war fortuna überhaupt
nicht mein ding
ok überhaupt nicht dafür aber jetzt doch
für eine menge
aber bescheid über dieses schreckliche
saison haben wir schlechtes ergebnis
genommen
okay aber trotzdem bei uns gibt es immer
den
den rücken stärkt so stern herzlichen
glückwunsch